tony gratacos bonsoir vous êtes le
secrétaire général de la gauche
républicaine et socialiste comment
est-ce que vous réagissez aux propos de
béchir a évidemment c'est insupportable
les difficultés qui sont faits à cette
jeune femme est et je crois oui qu'il
faut faciliter quand il ya une
immigration qui se passe bien une
intégration qui se fait correctement
dans la société dans la vie
professionnelle il faut faciliter
l'accès à des papiers à ces personnes là
et comment faciliter l'accès au papier
ces personnes là comment
établir peut-être des quotas comme ce
qui se passe au canada en
grande-bretagne aux etats-unis en
l'immigration choisie quotas
bon c'est vrai que pour un certain
nombre de personnes c'est un gros mot et
pourtant ce sont des débats qui ont
traversé toutes les familles politiques
et depuis très longtemps moi je crois
qu'il faut avoir un rapport laïcs et des
passionnés à l'immigration est quasiment
une approche scientifique de la question
il faut voir que derrière ces situations
cédé par ses exils il y a toujours des
drames et des difficultés pour autant il
faut qu'on est en france une méthode
d'accueil et d'intégration qui soit
adaptée et c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
clairement c'est pas le cas parce que
d'une façon générale et sur tous les
sujets l'état a déserté ses missions
régaliennes
donc il faut d'abord que on réfléchisse
aux critères d'accueil que l'on souhaite
mettre en place il faut qu'on ait un
débat asnières
il faut un les professions qui nous
intéresse le
comment dire les catégories de
population qu'on peut accueillir dans
des conditions convenables et combien on
peut en accueillir moi j'ai pas peur
d'avoir le débat sur le chiffre par
exemple on parle d'un manque de main
d'oeuvre actuellement que ce soit dans
les dans les restaurants ou dans le btp
est ce que une immigration choisie
là-dessus pourrait
être heureux mais alors l'immigration
choisie pour maintenir la pression sur
les salaires non parce que clairement
aujourd'hui vu le nombre de chômeurs
qu'on a en france est ce qu'on a besoin
d'aller chercher de la main d'oeuvre à
l'étranger non le problème des secteurs
on ne trouve pas de salarié c'est le
problème du niveau des salaires c'est
que les salaires sont trop bas les
conditions de travail trop difficile
donc commençons par augmenter les
salaires dans ces secteurs comme la
restauration le btp et on verra si on
manque de main d'oeuvre ou pas mais
quand on a plusieurs millions de
chômeurs on n'a pas besoin d'aller
chercher des gens à l'étranger et pour
les les cerveaux on parle de fuite de
cerveaux est ce qu'il faut aller
chercher
des personnes des étrangers capables il
y en a beaucoup j'ai plus le chiffre en
tête mais énormément d'étudiants
étrangers viennent travailler en france
on leur à la scandaleusement augmenter
les frais d'inscription à l'université
au contraire si on veut faire venir plus
de cerveau comme vous dites il faut
faciliter leur arrivée sur le territoire
et ce sont des personnes qui n'ont pas
vocation à rester très longtemps
d'ailleurs en général il reparte
quelques années après la fin de leurs
études pour autant ils enrichissent
notre savoir faire ils enrichissent
notre milieu scolaire oui il est
dramatique que des étudiants français
partent aujourd'hui aux états unis en
inde ou dans des pays du nord de
l'europe parce qu'ils vont être mieux
payés pour pouvoir appliquer ce qu'on
leur a appris en france et là encore
c'est la question des salaires la
situation des chercheurs par exemple en
france est dramatique le niveau de leur
salaire est désespérant et je comprends
qu à un moment quand on a passé autant
d'années à étudier on a envie de gagner
correctement sa vie et quand on est
invité par des grandes entreprises ou
des grands laboratoires étrangers avec
logement voiture etc accueil de la
famille prise en charge des enfants en
milieu scolaire je comprends qu'on
conçoit intéressés pour quitter le pays
anthony gratacos fait didier leschi le
directeur
général de l'office français de
l'immigration et de l'intégration a
estimé avant-hier dans marianne je cite
que nous sommes dans une impasse alors
évidemment il évoque le naufrage qui
s'est passé dans la manche mais aussi la
situation à la frontière entre la
pologne et la biélorussie aussi la grèce
qui a inauguré des nouveaux campements
de migrants comment et lutter
efficacement contre le sentiment
d'insécurité des français ouais alors
c'est compliqué de faire le lien vous
fait un lien direct entre immigration et
insécurité
bon
c'est rooney campagne oui oui non mais
prenez n'importe quel enfant dans
n'importe quelle partie du monde mettez
le dans un milieu aisé il évoluera bien
et il s'en sortira bien prenez n'importe
quel enfant de n'importe quelle partie
du monde et mettez le dans un milieu
défavorisé et forcément il aura des
problèmes donc alors évidemment on va
dire vous êtes de go je vous ramener
tout à la question sociale mais c'est
quand même extrêmement important on
parle pas je veux bien qu'on parle
d'insécurité mais est ce qu'on parle de
la ghettoïsation de ces populations en
france est ce qu'on parle de leur
situation par exemple scolaire le
meilleur le lycée le mieux doté de
seine-saint-denis est moins bien doté
que le lycée le moins bien dotées de
paris est ce normal est ce qu'il est
normal vous me parler d'insécurité est
ce qu'il est normal que les effectifs de
police et b c est ce qu'il est normal
qu'on ait fermé des tribunaux est ce
qu'il est normal qu'on ait cessé de
supprimer des fonctionnaires mans tous
les services de l'état qu'on ait fait
disparaître en milieu scolaire les
maîtres eux les maîtres rased les
infirmières les psychologues est ce
qu'il est normal qu'on ait supprimé
l'accompagnement en prison des gens qui
en sortent sous prétexte de maîtriser
les budgets mais le résultat il est là
le résultat il est que les français ils
ont un sentiment d'insécurité parce que
l'insécurité elle existe elle est pas
lié à l'immigration elle est liée au
fait que l'état a totalement déserté ce
qui est sa responsabilité
assurer la sécurité des français au
quotidien et c'est pas en achetant des
caméras de vidéosurveillance ou en
armant les policiers municipaux qu'on va
régler le problème il faut de l'humain
sur le terrain il faut des policiers
formés j'ai rencontré il ya quinze jours
à melun les syndicats de police qui
manifestaient devant la direction
départementale de la sécurité publique
je leur ai posé la question de
l'armement des policiers municipaux et
ils m'ont dit mais monsieur gratacos on
n'a pas le temps nous de nous de nous
former correctement
alors évidemment ils ont un uniforme ils
sont en danger il faut qu'ils puissent
être armé je suis pas d'accord et de ça
mais c'était leur point de vue mais nous
mêmes on n'a pas le temps de vous former
et vous vous pensez pas qu'un problème
là là des membres de la police nationale
des syndicalistes qui expliquent qu'ils
n'ont pas le temps de pouvoir se former
à leur mission donc on a un problème
global à revenir ce brillant et à
l'immigration choisie avec emmanuel
macron qui a exhorté jeudi dernier lors
de sa conférence de presse face aux
journalistes à organiser l'immigration
choisie entre l'europe et l'afrique
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
cette déclaration pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas il faut mettre le débat sur la table
il faut dire quand il faut dire combien
il faut dire quoi est il faut dire
pourquoi il faut l'expliquer à la fois
aux populations là bas et au peuple
français ici
merci anthony gratacos d'avoir répondu à
une question je réponds que vous êtes le
secrétaire général de la gauche
républicaine et socialiste